primero consideremos la expresión para
la suma de 9 y el resultado de 4 veces x
a mí me gusta primero utilizar la parte
que tiene x y veamos el resultado de 4
veces x lo podemos representar como 4x
a eso le sumaremos 9 así es que
pondremos con otro color más
esta es la primera expresión que tenemos
tenemos 4 veces x + 9 ahora selecciona
la respuesta que coincide con lo
siguiente - 1 tomaremos un -1
más el producto de menos 9 a eso le
sumaremos el producto de
-9 y esa expresión recuerda que cuando
hablamos de producto estamos hablando de
una multiplicación así es que si tenemos
menos 9 y esa expresión significa que
estaremos multiplicando menos 9 por la
expresión que tenemos aquí arriba que
será 4x
+ 9
ahora veamos cuáles de estas respuestas
coinciden con lo que tenemos tenemos
-9 eso es correcto menos 9 4x más 9
perfecto menos 1 ok
esta respuesta parece adecuada sin
embargo lo que hicieron aquí fue poner
el menos 1 al final para que tengamos
exactamente la misma expresión vamos a
mudar este menos 1 hacia la derecha y lo
colocaremos aquí menos 1 y eliminaremos
este
dejaremos entonces menos 94 x 9 menos
1 así es que esta respuesta se ve
adecuada
veamos si las demás respuestas también
son similares tenemos 9 positivo x 9 x
de entrada aquí el 4 está multiplicando
el x no el 9 así es que eliminaremos
esta 4x + 9 menos 1 parece similar sin
embargo este es un +9 y nosotros tenemos
un -9 esta respuesta la eliminamos y
finalmente tenemos un menos 4 x menos 9
aquí tenemos ya los esté aquí tenemos ya
este signo cambiado más 9 menos 9 y aquí
está restando menos 9 no multiplicando
así es que esta tampoco será la
respuesta nos vamos entonces con esta
respuesta menos 9 por 4 x más 9 y a todo
eso le arrestaremos 1 esta será la
respuesta correcta